No me contrataron en el trabajo que quería: difícil decir si es bueno o malo.
Me contrataron en el trabajo que quería: difícil decir si es bueno o malo.
Para mí, la parábola no consiste en ver el lado positivo
ni en esperar a ver cómo resultan las cosas,
es sobre qué tan ansiosos estamos por etiquetar una situación,
juzgarla e inmovilizarla como concreto.
Pero la realidad es mucho más fluida
y lo bueno y lo malo suelen ser cuentos incompletos
que nos contamos a nosotros mismos.
La parábola ha sido mi aviso
para entender que si me aferro al cuento de bueno o malo
pierdo mi capacidad para ver la situación con claridad.
Aprendo más cuando dejo a un lado el control,
cuando procedo sinceramente con curiosidad y asombro.
Pero hace siete años, cuando estaba embarazada de mi primera hija,
olvidé por completo esta lección.
Creí que sabía a ciencia cierta qué era bueno.
Cuando se trataba de tener hijos
creía que bueno era algo así como una superbebé,
una humana ultrasana sin un solo defecto
que prácticamente vestiría una capa y volaría hacia su futuro de superheroína.
Tomé ácido docosahexaenoico para asegurar que mi bebé
tuviera un cerebro superinteligente,
comí casi exclusivamente comida orgánica, me preparé para un parto sin medicamentos
e hice muchas otras cosas porque creí que me ayudarían
no solo a tener un buen bebé, sino el mejor bebé posible.
Cuando mi hija Fiona nació pesó 4 libras 12 onzas o 2 kilos 150 gramos.
El pediatra dijo que había solo dos explicaciones posibles
para su diminuto tamaño.
"O es mala la semilla", dijo, "o es mala la tierra".
No estaba tan agotada por el parto como para no entender su lógica:
mi recién nacida, según el doctor, era una mala planta.
Al final, me enteré de que mi hija tenía una enfermedad cromosómica muy rara
llamada síndrome de Wolf-Hirschhorn.
Le faltaba una parte de su cuarto cromosoma.
Y aunque mi hija estaba bien, estaba viva,
tenía su piel nueva de bebé y los ojos ónice más despiertos,
aprendí que la gente con su síndrome
tiene un significativo retraso en su desarrollo, y discapacidades.
Algunos nunca aprenden a caminar o a hablar.
Yo no tenía la ecuanimidad del granjero.
La situación me parecía inequívocamente mala.
Pero aquí es donde la parábola resulta útil
porque durante las semanas que siguieron a su diagnóstico
estuve sumida en la desesperación,
atascada en el cuento de que todo esto era trágico.
La realidad, afortunadamente, es mucho más fluida
y tiene mucho para enseñar.
A medida que empecé a conocer a esta persona misteriosa que era mi hija
mi cuento de tragedia perdió fuerza.
Resultó que mi pequeña amaba el reggae
y se sonreía cuando mi esposo la balanceaba al ritmo del reggae.
Sus ojos ónice se hicieron del azul más asombroso, como el del lago Tahoe,
y amaba usarlos para mirar intencional y fijamente a los ojos de otras personas.
A los cinco meses no podía mantener la cabeza alzada como otros bebés,
pero podía mantener este profundo e intencional contacto visual.
Un amigo dijo: "Es el bebé más despierto que he visto".
Pero donde yo veía el regalo de su calmada y atenta presencia
una terapeuta que vino a casa para trabajar con Fiona
vio una niña neurológicamente apagada.
Esta terapeuta estaba especialmente decepcionada
porque Fiona no giraba sola,
y me dijo que había que despertar su sistema neurológico.
Un día,
se agachó sobre el cuerpo de mi hija, la tomó por sus diminutos hombros,
la sacudió y dijo: "¡Despiértate, despiértate!"
Varios terapeutas visitaron la casa ese primer año
y generalmente se enfocaban en lo que creían que estaba mal en mi hija.
Yo estaba feliz cuando empezó a usar su mano derecha
para golpear una oveja de peluche colgante.
Pero el terapeuta estaba obsesionado con su mano izquierda.
Fiona no la usaba con frecuencia y solía cruzar los dedos de esa mano.
El terapeuta dijo que debíamos ponerle una tablilla,
que le quitaría la capacidad de usar esos dedos,
pero que los forzaría a una posición más normal.
Ese primer año empecé a notar un par de cosas.
Uno: parábolas antiguas aparte, mi hija tenía malos terapeutas.
(Risas)
Dos: tenía opciones, como la persona a la que le ofrecen una píldora roja
o una píldora azul.
Podía elegir ver las diferencias de mi hija como malas,
podía tratar de alcanzar la meta que sus terapeutas llamaban "nunca sabrías".
Amaban autofelicitarse cuando podían decir de un niño:
"Nunca sabrías que tiene 'retraso' o autismo o que es 'diferente'".
Podía creer que el buen camino
era el que borraba la mayor cantidad de diferencias posibles.
Por supuesto, hubiera sido desastroso
porque a nivel celular mi hija tenía un molde inusual.
No estaba diseñada para ser como otras personas; tendría una vida inusual.
Pero tenía otra opción:
podía abandonar mi cuento de que las diferencias neurológicas,
los retrasos en el desarrollo y las discapacidades son malas.
Por lo tanto,
también podía dejar mi cuento de que la vida es mejor en un cuerpo más apto.
Podía dejar mis prejuicios culturales
sobre lo que hace que una vida sea buena o mala
y simplemente observar la vida de mi hija desarrollarse con apertura y curiosidad.
Una tarde, Fiona estaba boca arriba y arqueó su espalda sobre la alfombra,
sacó su lengua a un lado de la boca
y consiguió hacer una torsión y caer sobre su barriga.
De ahí, se balanceó y rodó de nuevo hasta caer de espaldas.
Logró hacerlo una y otra vez, rodando y arrastrando sus 12 libras
hasta quedar bajo una mesa.
Al principio creí que estaba atascada, pero vi que se estiraba
para agarrar lo que había sido su objetivo desde el principio: un cable eléctrico.
Tenía un año.
Claro que muchos bebés de su edad están parándose y empezando a caminar.
Para algunos la situación de mi hija era mala:
una niña de un año que solo podía girarse.
Al diablo con eso, mi hija estaba disfrutando la libertad de su movilidad.
Me regocijé.
Por otro lado, lo que vi esa tarde fue a una bebé tirando un cable eléctrico,
así que, ya saben, difícil decir si es bueno o malo.
(Risas)
Noté que si no me aferraba a una idea
de lo que hace que una vida sea buena o mala
podía observar la vida de mi hija desenvolverse y verla por lo que era.
Era hermosa, era complicada, alegre, difícil...
en otras palabras: simplemente otra expresión de la experiencia humana.
Finalmente, mi familia y yo nos mudamos a otro estado de EE.UU.
y tuvimos suerte con nuestro nuevo lote de terapeutas.
No se enfocaban en lo que estaba mal en mi hija,
no veían sus diferencias como problemas a resolver.
Reconocían sus limitaciones, pero también veían sus fortalezas
y la celebraban por quién era.
La meta de los terapeutas no era que Fiona fuera lo más normal posible,
la meta era hacerla lo más independiente posible
para que alcance todo su potencial, como sea que eso luzca para ella.
La sociedad no comparte esta actitud positiva frente a las discapacidades.
Llamamos "defectos de nacimiento" a las diferencias congénitas
como si los seres humanos fuéramos objetos en una línea de ensamblaje.
A lo mejor sentimos lástima
cuando nos enteramos que un colega ha tenido un bebé con síndrome de Down.
Aclamamos una película taquillera sobre un suicida en silla de ruedas,
pese a que la gente real que usa silla de ruedas
dice que el estereotipo es injusto y dañino.
Y, a veces, nuestras instituciones médicas deciden qué vidas merecen ser vividas
como en el caso de Amelia Rivera,
una niña que tiene el síndrome de mi hija.
En el 2012 un famoso hospital de EE.UU. le negó inicialmente a Amelia
el derecho a un vital trasplante de riñón
porque según su formulario tenía "retraso mental".
Así es como el cuento de que las discapacidades son malas
se manifiesta en una cultura.
Pero hay un cuento contrastante que es sorprendentemente insidioso,
el cuento de que la gente con discapacidades intelectuales es buena
porque están aquí para enseñarnos algo mágico
o que son intrínsecamente angelicales, o que siempre son dulces.
Seguramente han escuchado este tipo de comentario discriminatorio:
"Ese niño con síndrome de Down es uno de los niños especiales de Dios"
o "La niña del andador y el aparato para comunicarse
es un precioso angelito".
Este cuento aparece en la vida de mi hija alrededor de Navidad
cuando cierta gente se regocija
ante la idea de verla con alas de ángel y aureola en la presentación navideña.
La insinuación es que estas personas no sufren las engorrosas complejidades
de ser humanos.
Y aunque en ocasiones, sobre todo cuando era bebé,
mi hija sí ha lucido angelical,
ha crecido para convertirse en el tipo de niño
que hace picardías, como cualquier otro niño.
Como cuando tenía cuatro años y empujó a su hermanita de dos.
Mi hija se merece el derecho a ser fastidiosa, como cualquier otro niño.
Cuando etiquetamos a una persona como terrible o angelical, mala o buena,
le robamos su humanidad: el desorden y complejidades que vienen con el título,
al igual que los derechos y dignidades correspondientes.
Mi hija no existe para enseñarme a mí o a Uds. algo, aunque sí me ha enseñado.
Número uno: cuántos 'palitos de queso'
puede comer en un día un ser humano de 10 kilos...
la respuesta es 5 palitos, para su información.
Y dos: el don de cuestionar las creencias de mi cultura
sobre qué hace que una vida sea buena y qué hace que sea mala.
Si me hubieran dicho hace 6 años
que mi hija a veces usaría un iPad para comunicarse, me hubiera parecido triste.
Pero ahora recuerdo el día en que le entregué su iPad
que contenía 1000 palabras,
cada una representada por un pequeño ícono o cuadrado en una aplicación.
Y recuerdo lo audaz y esperanzada que me sentí,
aún si algunos terapeutas dijeron que mis expectativas eran demasiado altas,
que Fiona nunca podría presionar esos objetivos diminutos.
Y recuerdo haber observado con admiración
mientras, poco a poco, aprendía a doblar su pequeño pulgar
y a presionar los botones para decir las palabras que quería
como 'reggae' y 'queso' y cientos de otras palabras que amaba,
pero que su boca no podía decir aún.
Después hubo que enseñarle palabras menos divertidas,
preposiciones como 'de', 'sobre' y 'en'.
Trabajamos en eso durante semanas, y de ahí recuerdo
haber estado sentada en el comedor, rodeada de parientes,
y, de la nada, Fiona usó su aplicación del iPad para decir:
"Popó en baño".
(Risas)
Difícil decir si es bueno o malo.
Mi hija es humana, eso es todo.
Y eso es mucho.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)